hey everyone so my name's Emily Robinson
should have the slides up here in a
second I'll be I'm talking about
building an a/b testing analytic system
with orange shiny so a little more about
me and first most importantly that's
Abby she is my part-time dog as I like
to say I borrow her for my parents so
I'm currently working as a data
scientist of data camp I'll go into
briefly what data camp is we'll make the
talk make more sense but it's an online
learning platform for data science which
has courses practice sessions it's very
interactive I've been an our user for
about seven years so I was lucky enough
to go to Rice University and when I was
studying how the Wycombe was there as a
statistics professor and so he had
designed some of the our courses that's
why I first learned are I also and and
you know as Jared said socializing is a
big part of this conference so you know
when you see me around the next couple
of days
some things I really enjoy talking about
our building and finding data science
community and part of the Our Lady's New
York City chapter one of the reasons I
really enjoy programming is our is that
I find it a very friendly and welcoming
community and so I hope you find that
here too I also like talking about
diversity and stem so the sudden part of
the our ladies I really appreciate Jared
cares a lot about this too and you can
see that reflected in the speaker lineup
and of course our so do you do you
briefly this is what you might see if
you go to a data camp course so as I
said it's an online interactive learning
platform so with Python are over 180
courses projects as well and we're based
on a subscription-based model so I'll
talk about that a little bit later but
basically people can register and then
we have both b2c so like just you know
one of you just signing yourself up and
business-to-business subscriptions so
first I want to make sure we're all on
the same page and define what is a B
testing so if we have a user Joe and Joe
logs on
and says I want to learn deep learning
and so Joe comes today to camp and they
might see something like this right so
this is a course page and it says write
deep learning in Python great but if
we're running an a/b test they might
also see something like this instead so
there are a couple differences here but
the big one we'll see is that we have
the registration page so basically a/b
testing is about when you have to you
have your randomly assigning people when
they come and visit your website to one
of two or more different experiences so
the idea basically here is that instead
of just launching something and try to
measuring what change you're looking at
and saying okay because we're randomly
assigning people the only difference
between those who saw the control and
the treatment should just be not sure
what I think it's catching up to me now
the only difference between the control
and treatment should be what we changed
on the webpage so if there is a
difference between those groups and
things like a registration rate or
conversion rate then that is a sign that
what we changed is the reason that they
had this okay not sure what's happening
here so I want to talk a little bit
about me before data camp so we saw
previously
it's just sounds like a mind of its own
so before data camp I was working at
Etsy and Etsy if you're not familiar
it's a big online e-commerce platform
and Etsy has you know over it was been
running experiments for more than six
years by time I joined it had students
you hear over five data engineers
working on the experimentation platform
over a thousand metrics computed for
each experiment so is this very
sophisticated online learning sorry a
very sophisticated a be testing system
and so I came into that and that's where
I first started using a/b testing and
you know I also really benefited with
these five data engineers there was a
very nice UI for experiments so when I
came in the every morning I would sort
of get my tea sit down and I would see
catapult all our internal tool and it
listed all experiments that were
currently running and the metrics for
each of them so what we see here is that
we have two metrics this is from a blog
post how Etsy handles a/b testing and we
see that you know okay there are two
metrics one of them there was no change
from the control of the treatment and
one of them it says not enough data so
what does that look like and the nice
thing is when you have these great
engineers who know PHP we get fancy
little pop-ups and so we see here that
okay there was no detectable change we
get what was the observed rate what's
the change what's the confidence
interval p-value power and then if we
see not enough data we would see that
okay your metric is not powered yet for
1% change so this is how we help solve
the peeking problem so checking the data
too soon so we can see yes the p-value
is significant here but we're saying be
a little cautious because you might be
checking the results too early so this
is the system I was working with and
then I come into data camp and data camp
I was brought in to help build their a/b
testing system and this is basically how
I felt so I came in here this is me
record I had not lied on my resume they
knew they knew sort of my experience at
Etsy and a/b testing but you know what
the difference here was that I wasn't
coming into a fully formed system so I
wasn't just doing you know working in a
system that was already functioning I
there was no system for planning
analyzing or presenting experiment
results we hadn't really started doing
that yet at data camp and there were
also was no data engineer to help build
it so this was all on me
so my first lesson I want to give in
this talk is to build tools that empower
yourself so when I started a B testing
is really about one thing and that is
conversions so it's all about who did
this and then did that so it may be if
you're an e-commerce website maybe
that's buying for data Kim might be with
subscriptions but we could even count a
conversion as something like a course
start right it doesn't necessarily have
to be paying money and so this is really
a you know at first this than that so
who here has had questions like you know
first who tried X then did Y who are the
people what
of people who did acts then did why what
was the last thing people did before
doing why what are all the things people
did after doing X so these types of
question these are time based questions
and you know with an a/b testing I'd
have exactly these types of questions so
I might do something and talking about
all right what about a subscription rate
so if I had a pricing page what course
did people start after seeing the course
search page for the first time okay what
were the ad clicks that had a course
start within two days so these are again
are like time-based questions right and
this sounds like maybe it's kind of
simple but I want to walk through three
users of actually some of the challenges
that are here so if we look at three
example users of data camp and this is
their path so this is over time we see
for example Josh and Lynn and they have
their pageviews and conversions and
again depending on the context of
conversion might be a course start and
the page view might be an ad click or a
course search page so and then we have
Steve so I want to go through and like
how okay if I were looking at this what
would be the connections I would draw
depending on my question so if I had the
course started after first course search
page so I'm looking at Josh here and
then I want to see okay so what's the
first course search page and where is
the first course start okay so it's
those two great so Josh that was kind of
easy alright let's go on to Lynn so with
Lynn we see that Lynn has the course
start before she had a course search
page view and so that is then we're
connecting the second course start right
because we need to have the course
started after the course search page we
don't care about what Lynn is done
before and then the final one Steve we
can see that here we have right we do a
look slightly longer time period all
right so there's his course start his
course search page view and we connect
those two seems simple okay now what if
we changed it up and we're looking at
all ad clicks followed by a course start
within two days and this is a very
arbitrary time period but now we see
right josh has multiple
convergence so we see all right he had
the ad click at first and then of course
start and then he had two more ad clicks
and each of them was followed by the
same course start but we want so we draw
both those connecting lines and then we
see Lin as well she just has one and
then Steve we see actually is none at
all so Steve's ad click is too far away
from the course start so when I was
doing all of this I had this kind of
very lengthy repetitive code and I was
saying all right so if I was doing a
left join you guys summarize get the
first registration you know then kind of
doing some ad counts percentage et
cetera so this you know it is a little
bit hard to switch back and forth so if
I was switching from okay I want to take
their first followed by the next one if
I want to do it within a time period you
know I'd sort of be redoing a lot of
code and it wasn't that easy to switch
back and forth between them and then you
click through yep so there's lots of
copying and pasting which you know as we
know as coders we don't want to do too
much of that it can read to mistakes and
I had to it was hard to switch between
different types of funnels so the
solution here is you know more possible
questions we might have right so even
more than the two I started the front
who subscribed for the first time after
seeing the pricing page so then I care I
want to make sure they've never
subscribed before they saw the pricing
page I'm just looking at first-time
subscribers and you know what was the
last page people saw before starting the
course what are all the courses people
started after visiting the home page so
a bunch of different if this then that
you know inner joins just people who did
both left joins percentage etc so I have
all these types of questions and you
know the next step for doing that is
click next slide you know and when you
have a repetitive tasks we have Hadley
Wickham here telling us we got a time to
write a function right if you're doing
lots of copy and pasting and what I'll
actually add to that is that it's also
time sometimes to write a package so
when you have a function can be great
you know but a package can help bundle
all of that together and make it a
little bit easier to use across
different scripts
so we only had one issue here okay great
now it's time to write a package and
that was that I had never written a
package before so I was coming and I
said okay I have this task and how am I
gonna do this can you click the next
slide keep going so I was sitting there
like this poor a very confused pug
saying I don't really know all right
I sort of I'm gonna listen to the great
Hadley Wickham you know my teacher of
old but I don't really know how to write
this package now fortunately I did
really luck out in my workplace and
that's because I had David Robinson
why are you oh oh wait a second not
sorry not not that David Robinson if
only no no I had this David Robinson who
actually is my brother as well so he
familiar with him he worked at Stack
Overflow he's chief data scientists a
data camp and and written some great
packages like tidy Texan broom that you
might have used so Dave helped me out in
starting this package funnel join so you
can find it online at github data camp
funnel join and what it does is it takes
different types of funnels so whether
you're saying I want the first time
someone did this and then the first
thing you know first time they did X and
then the first y after that I want all
X's and Y's from the same person that
happened within two hours I want any you
know combination of the pair and so you
can really easily switch in these
time-based joins and I'm just going to
give a brief demonstration of how the
code might look so if we go to the next
slide this is a after join function and
that's funnel joins main function and
there are a couple of points here so we
see first if you keep clicking through
that we have the first table so a
pricing page view and then we have a
second table whether people subscribed
we tell okay what are the user column
names what are the time columns so this
is telling it okay how do I tell you
know which happened first and second
then I have the type of after join which
you can read about in the documentation
and so in this case I want to take the
first time someone view the page and
their first subscription afterwards and
finally the type
deep liar join its like an inner left
etc so on the next slide I'll show how
it changes really easily if you want to
do a different type of time-based joins
so now we're looking at within gap so if
you go back one slide we see that this
is saying now all we changed was the
type to within gap and then we looked at
the we added this argument DT which is
saying add if time so now it's only
joining them when there's a two days or
smaller gap and so what I've done here
is I've tried to make it really easy to
switch to look at different types of
time-based joins on the next slide I'll
show how you know funnel join there's
many different funnel types as I
mentioned so there's last before first
after smallest gap any-any etc it
supports all type of deep higher joins
so whether you want to do a left join
and anteus MA etc bugfixes pull request
feature requests all welcome as I said
it's up on github and I really encourage
you to try to yourself I will say a bit
of a note of caution and that it is
still under construction we're very
actively using it at data camp but just
be a little careful oh and also it does
work on remote tables so if any of you
have used DB prior right so you can
basically it's translating sequel code
in our funnel join because it uses deep
I on the back end will work with remote
tables so now I want to go into my next
lesson which is on a be testing
everything that can go wrong will go
wrong so basically we've had a couple
things happen at data camp when I was
first starting out and it even happens
at you know old shops like Etsy - so
some things that has happened
if we keep clicking through is that
people are put in both the controller
the treatment group and this should
never happen right the idea is you're
randomly assigned based on your cookie
and you should stay in your controller
treatment group so some of the other
things that happen is that people in the
experiment have no page views so we see
this experiment start event but we
haven't recorded basically any other
activity on data camp people have
multiple experiments starts in the same
group so okay they had stayed in the
control but they should only enter the
experiment one why are we seeing them
having five experiments starts there
aren't the same number of people in the
control of the treatment
so here that's called the big issue
called bucketing excuse so it should be
that if you said it's gonna be 50/50
that's what it should end up being and
if it's not something has gone wrong in
your setup and experiment starts didn't
have cookies so we couldn't track the
user so if we didn't have recorded with
the experiments start a cookie we
couldn't see what else they did most I'm
not sure how I ended up with that red
dot yeah it's just hanging out there
so one thing we did was that a be
testing sanity checks so this was saying
okay let's try to figure out early on
and make sure that these things aren't
happening once we are finding these data
integrity issues so you always need to
check your assumptions when you're
making so we had never thought that we'd
have people without page views or that
we'd have people and you know coming in
who didn't have a cookie but we were
starting to find this so we realized
okay in every experiment we need to
check and make sure this isn't happening
you click the next slide so the initial
solution if we go through here is that
all right had all these arts code I was
like okay let me check this thing is
anyone at the experiment more than once
so bucketing skew you know if we keep
going there with some things like okay
is there does everyone have a cookie and
so I was just like writing these lines
of our code and copying that into every
script I was running for an experiment
so you know is anyone switched variant
etc what proportion of domain user IDs
are null so just all these different
problems and if we go to the next slide
we can see that this is a similar
problem to before so you've seen this
advice when you've written the code
three times write a function and I
actually want to change that a little
bit so if we click through we'll see
when you've run the same process three
times actually she's just making a
dashboard so sometimes it's very handy
to write the same function you know but
that still is a little bit repetitive so
I always say build tools that also
empower others so on this next slide
we'll see a tool that I've built for
data camp which is a health checks
dashboard and so this is all fake
numbers but what we see is now for each
experiment we can monitor how many what
percent of duplicate cookies how many
cookies are multiple variations which
how many have no pageviews
variation size which will warn us if
there are an unequal split between the
control and the treatment so this is
something that is even easier than me
running the same function for each
experiment is just have it run
automatically in the dashboard and on
the next slide we'll see that I've also
built some dashboards for monitoring
experiments so as we click through here
we see first we see although we can
choose to see with running experiments
the recent experiments etc then we look
at experiment metrics okay do we want to
look at registrations course starts
exercise starts we can see now for each
experiment all right what's the rate in
the control and the treatment percentage
change and the p-value and it'll change
colors based on that p-value and if we
click to the next one we'll see that we
also add confidence intervals so it's
not so even I'm very lucky at data camp
that a lot of people have some technical
and statistical skills but even if you
don't I think you can sort of grasp an
intuition from this that all right so if
the confidence interval is very far from
zero and small maybe it's real change if
it's you know just barely not
overlapping maybe we were a little more
skeptical so if we look at the next
slide all right how can we keep leveling
up so I had a common request of what
percent increase can we detect in a
two-week test and so the next part it
looks at alright so I'd be answering
this question and I was getting to the
point where I could answer it you know
pretty easily but I you know it would be
better if other people could answer it
for themselves so if we click to the
next part do do you know can I make a
tool that people can answer this and
without code so even with having some
technical colleagues sometimes you don't
want them to have to switch to code so
it's going from delivering information
to discovering information and you know
I said all right challenge accepted how
can I make a dashboard that people will
be able to do this and on the next slide
we'll see the impact calculator that I
created so this was here you could
choose what's the population of your
test
what's the url's do we only want signed
in signed out people etc and then we can
see all right
this is how many people are in the
courses how many what percentage our
chapter etc and on the next slide what
I've paired this with is a power
calculator so we'll say okay based on
that you will be able to detect this
size increase so now people could look
for themselves and say oh if I want to
do something on this page well it only
has 10% of people starting a course that
will I need a 20% increase that's
probably not gonna happen
so just in conclusion going the next
slide we see these are the main three
lessons right which is first build tools
that empower yourself so this was the
funnel join package and the second last
one was to build tools that also empower
other people which are often dashboards
and finally everything that can go wrong
will go wrong so definitely check your
assumptions and many thanks to the
growth and data science teams a data
camp to my co-authors Anthony Baker and
Dave Robinson to the funnel joint
package into the analytics and data
engineering teams at Etsy with that
thank you all so much you can find my
blog hooked on data org if you want to
try out final join yourself as again you
can find it at github comm slash data
camp slash funnel join and thank you
[Applause]
you